und wir haben eine gottverdammte tief
rüstung am stapeln lieben freunde werden
jetzt schnell wie sonst was you blabla
ich hab eigentlich alles so freunde ich
habe gerade ein flugzeug der stadt
gehört ich glaube das war gott meine
lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge minecraft
hero auf dem arm ein kräftiges auf dem
hero server so ist richtig ich nehme
jetzt endlich mal wieder nach einer
woche auf weil ich ja mit den sehr viel
vorproduzierten über die
weihnachtsfeiertage es regnet und das
macht das ist ganz schön weil dann kann
ich endlich ach so ich dachte schon
deswegen passt jetzt auf dem server
deswegen kann ich jetzt endlich wieder
einmal so auf den server gehen weil ich
aber die weihnachtsfeiertage mit familie
viel unterwegs war skifahren des
vertrages bescheiden und wir haben schon
eine stadtmauer das hat wirklich jetzt
umgesetzt schön wenn wir können uns
jetzt erstmal ganz kurz hier angucken
und ich muss nämlich los und die fifa
wollte jetzt endlich vervollständigen
und zwar brauche ich noch die hose
also ich brauche auf jeden fall wolle
und x6 deswegen bot komma das ist die
erste stadt nämlich mit einer richtigen
stadtmauer das ist ganz schön habe ich
nicht mit kev noch darüber geredet dass
wir so was auf jeden fall noch brauchen
der ist ganz cool dass der das jetzt so
umgesetzt hat ihr könnt das hat mir
angucken habe ich den flug zauberstab
eigentlich mag ich hab erst recht ich
brauche auf jeden fall schlug zauberstab
ein kleiner rückblick auf die letzten
folgen war es heißt auch die letzten
folgen also auf einen auf die welche
fläche ist auf die 20 acts folge dadurch
zum ersten mal ein neues micro
beziehungsweise nicht mal neues micro
sim ein neues mischpult ich hoffe dass
der sound jetzt ein bisschen besser ist
einige meinten dass das ganze mehr halt
das meint meint allerdings nur ganz
wenige deswegen möchte ich mal ganz kurz
noch mal eure meinung hören euch in den
kommentaren wissen was ihr denn meint
halt
das zu sehr wenn ich das jetzt so hier
alles hier normal habe oder sagt ihr leo
passt alles weil da ist mir eure meinung
auf jeden fall sehr wichtig habe ich ihr
noch irgendwas zu essen würden
hirsch nichts mehr drin habe ich nicht
aber das hier sind erste sind die
spiegel ist meine noch welche dass sich
hier dann auch noch irgendwelche
essenzen habe in welche ecke lizenzen
sind allerdings nicht mehr hier ist noch
was zu essen dann im braunen rucksack
man in viele dass da was drin ist
ich habe irgendwie so viele rucksäcke
auf einmal das ist heftig da ist nix
drin das schön
ich brauche einen fliegt zauberstab ich
weiß gar nicht ist und meine anderen
kaputt also das was ich in dieser folge
schaffen möchte ist meine tiefe
vervollständigen und ich wollte mir doch
bald versuchen so ein miniatur extra
herz zu machen damit ich davon ein
bisschen mehr mehr herzen dann bist du
bescheid
ich habe hier so viele sachen auf einmal
nach diesen ganzen touren jetzt ne das
ist heftig 31 mm ist mein auch voll
viele dass der crystal bau viel besser
ist als der legia bogen weil beim liga
bogen kommen ebenfalls ab 10 electric
essenzen ich habe zehn electric essenzen
alter ist das heftig was ich suche jetzt
einfach mal electric darf so darf ich
kann da ist auch keiner drin da ist auch
keiner drin das ist auch keiner drin da
auch nicht so jetzt müssen wir eben die
rucksäcke
nee nee so die beiden nee ich habe ohne
wird keinen electric stuff mehr
das ist heftig habe ich dann noch diese
diese dieser diese diese diese dateien
habe ich ja kaum einer müsste eigentlich
erst mal reichen
so jetzt eben hier ich kann auch
eigentlich im dienst das machen na gut
ich möchte nämlich nur kurz rumfliegen
und ich möcht ich möchte auf jeden fall
tintenfische muss sich töten und ich
muss scharf auf jeden fall finden
so jetzt erst mal verzaubert wo können
wir dann dahin fliegen wo ist dann
relativ viel wasser
ich glaube da da da da hin ist doch aber
da war ich schon oder guck mal da hier
ist alles auch schon so abgesperrt das
ist ganz schön finde ich finde kev als
könig macht spaß wenn ich könig wäre es
über die ferien könnte ich auch eine
menge was reißen wofür ich mich zum
beispiel einsetzen würde ist das war
dass wir eine richtige
kriegsvorbereitungen kommen also dass
jeder ein spezialgebiet bekommt fast
donnerstag um weil das jeder quasi ein
spezialgebiet bekommt worauf er quasi
zugeteilt wird
also dann irgendwie das einer dafür zu
senden zuständig ist dass er so weise
nicht portale macht zu den anderen
städten die anderen machen dann
irgendwie auch hier sieht es gut nach
den fischen aus nein dann macht ein
anderer wiederum die ganzen schwerter
und so also kehrt wollte mich also gar
zum könig wählen weil er denkt dass ich
dadurch die vernünftige seriosität hätte
ich weiß nicht was er sich dabei gedacht
hat oder bedrückt mit macht dabei aber
gut nein freunde was aber worüber ich
dir reden wollte während ich unterwegs
war war ja wieder perfekt vorbereitet
ihrem start
meine weihnachtsfeiertage was ich so
bekommen habe ich habe euch gefragt was
ihr euch gewünscht habt den in der
letzten folge
jetzt möchte ich mal wissen was ihr
bekommen habt eure wünsche in erfüllung
gegangen sind natürlich dass das
wichtigste an weihnachten ist mit mit
freunden wieder zu treffen alte bekannte
komma hd joint ja egal ich bin der stadt
wenn er nicht schreibt dann ist da
gerade richtig richtig verzweifelt
irgendeinen verdammten spiegel zu finden
hey kommando nee also alles was ich mir
gewünscht hatte war ein ipad und das hab
ich auch bekommen da bin ich sehr froh
oder weil es nicht also das ist halt
immer ganz schwierig dass ich dann so
abends im bett noch so serien gucken
kann oder filme gucken kann und so oder
auch einfach wenn man dann ein referat
eine präsentation vorbereitet
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich komme ja
zuhause suchen wird also keine ahnung
ich bin da relativ weit weg zu hause
ich habe übrigens auch einen spiegel von
zu hause von da ist gar nicht schlimm
wenn ich jetzt irgendwie mich richtig
verfliegen
ich bin nicht zu hause falls du mich
willst aber das ist doof dass ich nie
komplett alleine auf den fahrradständern
das merke ich wie ich habe ein ipad
bekommen dieses ipad er da dingsbums und
sonst halt noch so kleinigkeiten ich
habe auch dieses kompressor mischpult
hier bekommen und sonst halt nur so
kleinigkeiten wie in die t shirt oder
süßigkeiten von verwandten dann immer so
20 euro oder so so ein paar sachen halt
schreibt mir einfach spaß die ich wette
ich wette wer in der zwischenzeit hat er
sich versucht einen spiegel zu machen
ich könnte schwören also der hat ja
spiegelt also ich hab ja auch spiegel
aber ich weiß nicht soll ich einfach mal
zu gommel fliegende versuchen jetzt
pushen soll ich denke ich habe da gar
kein netbook ich habe da gar keine
verzögerung darauf und da ist es relativ
egal
übrigens bald noch leute ich habe mich
ja beschwert dass das ja doch nicht geht
mit dem ende james ford dass ich da
irgendwie damit keinen schaden bekomme
aber an städtische tintenfisch tinte
yahoo sterbt ihr blöden pizza dass ich
komme
ich will mir erst mal ganz kurz hier
noch mal ganz kurz den shader dafür aus
weil unter wasser es ist besser wenn man
keinen shader hat glaube ich ja dass ich
sehe auf jeden fall schon mal mehr die
fdp drei habe ich hier steht jetzt auch
eben wohnte auch jetzt liege ich hier
wieder raus so ok die tintenfische habe
ich und jetzt auf dem rückweg muss ich
jetzt gucken ob ich irgendwie ich weiß
gar nicht findet ihr das besser wenn ich
keinen shader drin habe oder wenn ich
einen fehler drin haben das ist nämlich
immer so die frage sollte man sich ja
shader mit mega geil ich weiß nicht ob
ihr zu die die leute die jetzt hier
geradezu schauen würde die hofer würdet
ihr sagen ja lieber mit shader oder
lieber und stellt dabei so sieht ohne
scheider aus guckt euch das an und mit
shader sieht so aus also ich weiss nicht
ihr müsst das entscheidende mir ist das
relativ egal was ihr damals bei dem es
nicht nur 2 ph etwas was ihm 1 in visp
gaal was ich nehme es ihnen ja noch
irgendwie sexy k lizenzen sein oder es
ist krass dass wir hinten auch schon
leute würden schon dass du alles
abgewürgt haben juhu hexal ist jedoch
bestimmt noch mehr
jetzt suche ich bestimmt wieder
irgendwie und jetzt mal in welcher höhe
luca du hast auch dahin gewirkt und da
war ich so ok koenic nein aber ich finde
das lohnt sich auch nicht irgendwie dann
dafür zurück zu laufen
ich war ja auf jeden fall noch nicht
weil das oft als web ist schwarz zurück
zu den schildern schreibt mir einfach da
mal was das denn das war bestimmt so
eine falle dies aber auch schon
ausgelöst
ich frage mich halt einfach was was ihr
da so wollt also sagt jeder ernährung
ich werde keinen rappen bis 19 ich mich
nach hause wollte ob komme da nicht
irgendwo ist weil dann würde ich glaub
ich direkt wegfliegen
er ist mir noch mal eben was fressen wie
komme ich fliege zurück zu statt blau
ich habe da ja auch sonst so einen
wegpunkt und da ist noch ein
lexikalisches in schools mal werde ich
mich reporter hätte hätte ich die nicht
gesehen ich brauche eigentlich keine
mehr aber man kann die ja immer war ganz
gut gebrauchen weil ich mir auch noch
ein helm machen muss für meine skela
da habe ich jetzt schon wieder drei ich
finde wenn ich noch einen finde habe ich
auch noch die scala mal wieder komplett
wenn ich jetzt genug level hätte wenn
unserem opfer und so mock falle
funktioniert sogar meinte cap in einem
video das habe ich bei ihm gesehen
darauf habe ich nämlich sehnlichst
gewartet das sind noch mehr aber die
braucht erstmal nicht ich brauche immer
noch schafe die funktioniert bei käfer
wieder habe ich in seinem video gesehen
ich guck mal ob ich auch in der lage
wenn die zu benutzen weil er meinte dass
die ein bisschen komplizierter gebaut
sei und so das ist doch bestimmt ex ksc
ist nicht aber hier für ein schaf eine
wende gegeben
der predator damit 2 gegeben und zu
sagen gibt schneider welche ja okay das
müsste eigentlich reichen weil es jetzt
können wir auch die wolle schwarz färben
ich nehme trotz schwarz nimmt trotz man
hier noch ein bisschen mehr mit man kann
ja nie wissen vielleicht brauchen wir da
noch ein bisschen und wir sind geradezu
viele von daher ist das ganz gut falls
doch mal etwas kaputt geht von der
rüstung und ihr schreibt mir also
einfach in die kommentare was was ihr so
alles bekommen habt dann wird mich auf
jeden fall interessieren weil ich weiss
nicht ihr seid so leute die das hier
gucken die sind ja schon ersetzt nicht
beleidigend verstehen aber ihr seid ja
schon relativ viel vom pc welt guckt
dann wahrscheinlich auch simon oder dna
oder sogar einfach ab und zu vorbei und
spielt vielleicht doch selber minecraft
und auch wenn man einfach nur ein
bisschen was spielt ist man halt gleich
schon gamer abgestellt wird von der
community diverse von den von den medien
das ist einfach so da können wir nichts
dran ändern das ist einfach so was ihr
so bekommen habe ich meine ihr habt euch
hundertprozentig einige von euch haben
nicht bestimmt ne ps3 ein iphone oder
irgendwelche spieler gewünscht da kann
ich meine hand ins feuer legen dass sich
jeder von euch irgendwie sowas gewünscht
hat wenn das nicht schon hat und
deswegen wird mich das ganz besonders
doll interessieren was ihr so bekommen
habe ich bin jetzt wieder zu hause
meiner stadt
man hätte meine ich dass ich vom ersten
bis zum 16
glock stock sind blog aber auch cool für
stahl jemand
trotzdem bisschen sonst wenn komme hier
ist eine ich würde euch jetzt schon ich
flieg weg weil ich auch keine chance
aber eine rüstung nicht verzaubert ist
und nicht mehr vollständig ist
ich finde es auch durch das man im haus
nicht sicher ist so egal tief schwarzen
wolle
blackpool leder leder habe ich so ein
kleiner knopf männer leder und der hexal
diana okay das bei mir immer so ich
mache mal so ein paar sachen frau wir
sind auch schon bei grey wir möchten
gray links und buemi ins heck und boni
habe ich habe ich nicht knochen
irgendwie noch man löscht das ärgerlich
da knappen nein ich brauche die wolle
verdammt so dass ein mann am bug
tatsachen ihre ich habe immer angst dass
sein sohn gamal hd einfach gleich mal um
die ecke erscheint so jetzt machen wir
mal so ein bisschen von den grauen
sachen ob man das ist so ärgerlich so
eine kacke rüstung zu machen wieso
kriegt denn jetzt nicht da geht das nur
mit weiß man jetzt hier schon so so so
so auch schon wieder falsch so da sind
die fibu sowie geht diese blöde rose
hier leder und nenne als baustein stream
wieder für ihn und jetzt habe ich auch
noch fünf leder choir dass ein player
für mich hier dir das trinkt kaum noch
da oben und jeder mexikaner diamond sein
doch die tief leggins und wir haben eine
gottverdammte tief rüstung am start und
lieben freunde werden jetzt schnell wie
sonst was you so und jetzt habe ich erst
mal die befristung dass man den kopf auf
sollte damit ich ihnen natürlich nach
dem tod noch besitze so
jetzt mal die schuhe ich glaube das
schaffe ich sogar noch zwölf brauche ich
dafür ja gut gefalle müllentsorgung ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt funktioniert
diesem opfer
eigentlich dürfte ich dafür sogar ein
relativ schlechtes schwert benutzen
können das habe ich dann soll ich habe
gar keine schlechten schwerter glaube
ich zurzeit mit ich muss das einfach mal
alle lässt irgendwann sortieren
ja ich habe gerade echt gar nichts mit
ich habe drei mexikaner ist ja ok ich
muss das jetzt vielleicht mal einfach
gleich irgendwie ändert ein
schrotthändler jones motto das cool das
kam mir sogar nehmen das ist ja unsere
dienste hier unseres schweren pakets ja
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal dass hier
dafür bricht jetzt nicht irgendwie
noch falle müllentsorgung obwohl er als
habe ich daran gedacht okay gut dass ich
zeige euch das mal da das ist irgendwie
so aufgebaut also kämpfer da selbst
schon ein blick rein gegeben da sind ein
paar sachen halt drin da bleibt mein
gott ich bin so schnell bedient die
harmonie das ist mega krass das kommt
bestimmt gleich komme hier sich
irgendwohin teleportiert also ich finde
es auch schön damit zum wollen glaube
ich den baum abgesetzt hatte ich find's
ganz schön die mauer die stadtmarke noch
ein bisschen schöner sein aber dieses
portals nix das ist die müllentsorgung
ich habe es jedoch jetzt angemacht oder
oder das braucht erstmal ein bisschen
ist das bond so dass die kabel schnell
geht jetzt hier hoch und da rein das
heißt es müsste theoretisch an seien
keine ahnung gut ich würde jetzt gern
sortieren allerdings ist der gang auf
dem server und habe ich ich habe weniger
tore als kommt ich habe so wenig tore
mittlerweile das ist heftig ich sehe das
auch immer der in dem seine todes konnte
jeder sein tod eintragen muss damit
etwas mit dem server so vergleichen
können auch den kopf wir noch eben
machen und zwar ob ich irgendwo noch
eine hecke
da sind drei dass keiner weiß auch
keiner auch keine auch keine
auch keine
auch keine ja gut dann kann ich jetzt
nicht den kopf machen so ich weiß nicht
ich bin mega hellen der face com alter
dass sich ja jetzt erst entschuldigung
tschuldigung ich glaube dass das ist
einfach mega hell draußen deswegen rau
darunter scheinen gerade heftigst die
sonne aber hier das geht irgendwie
funktioniert nicht so wie es sein soll
oder irgendwas habe ich dieses
ausgemacht und hab ich das jetzt an
gemacht ich habe auch keine mops ihn
wieder keiner ran müssen überschreiben
wie genau das funktioniert die folge
kommen nämlich direkt heute noch online
sogar ich packe jetzt erstmal so ein
paar wertvolle sachen überall rein damit
ich später das so ein bisschen hier noch
sortieren kann
so viele proben stehe die ich alle gar
nicht brauchen okay in den letzten drei
minuten sortiere ich jetzt noch ein ganz
klein bisschen hiervon ist sonst erst
mal nix wertvoll aus den rucksäcken
könnte ich noch nicht mal diese ganzen
und wertvollen sachen hier irgendwo hin
dass das volk hat ist auch schon wieder
voll
ja ich mache bald endlichen lagersystem
meiner lieben freunde macht ihr keinen
stress so kommt doch noch mal ran die
strings und ihr und jetzt kommen wir die
rucksäcke in dem schwarz des nix drin
genau dann kommt da rein
in ihm hier nämlich erstmal alles raus
was da so drin ist weil ich will erstmal
die ganzen rucksack leer haben dass wenn
ich auf reisen geht das japan rucksack
mitnehmen und dann ist das sind ja so
viel wertvolle sachen und das ist
wertvoll warum sie das ökoprofit anderen
mein gott warum ist das wurde jetzt ein
wert folgen glaube ich dass plate nicht
so dass kann ich dafür wieder rausnehmen
netter watson watson sind wertvoll
sonst nix der rest kommt da ein ja
kommen die kiste hier ist bald auch
wieder voll
[Musik]
hier ist noch ein bisschen platz und
muss ich mir dabei recht einfach mal
eine kiste machen wo ich hab noch marmor
stellen der kommenden stellt jetzt
einfach mal dahin irgendwo da stand dann
hier noch hin
irgendwie so gar keine ahnung dass die
scale arm und dies ist glaube ich
komplett wieder für dieses komplett voll
aber dies ließ auch komplett verzaubert
glaube ich ja die bringt okay was muss
ich denn sonst hat es um ändern
ja ich brauche einfach neue kisten ich
habe doch glaube ich hier irgendwie
kisten reingetan oder da nicht zu
behindern er wo habe ich hier erkennt 38
kisten
ich habe kein alter kamerad komme es hat
sich angewiesen spiegel ich mache jetzt
einfach mal noch zwei kisten hin
für so unnötige kacke die ich nicht
brauche ich werde das bald wirklich
alles sortiert bald eine komplette
sortier folge machen deswegen könnte mir
jetzt schon mit dem schreiben über dich
dann reden soll
und wenn ich das machen so der rucksack
ist auch leer sein kommentar in die
spiegel habe ich immer dabei und jetzt
die beiden noch hier sind wir sind ja
nur fast wertvolle sachen drin alter so
ich dir kommt erstmal das raus hier
tanzen und wertvollen sachen kommt hier
ein do do do do the deep end of eternity
den lege ich meinen garten ob wir sind
schon wieder bei den 19 anhalt minuten
das macht er keine ahnung was macht
vielleicht zaubert herren ich weiß nicht
dies wolle nicht dass wollen nicht dass
tapis diese ganz interessant freuen ich
freue mich fressen so alles andere kommt
hier rein kriegen wir nur die ganze
existenzen hier zauberstab du so ist
jetzt leer
ja ich will nicht überziehen aber ich
mache jetzt mal eben ganz kurz weil ich
das ganze jetzt noch eben schnell
aussortieren muss so feile diese scheiße
blöcken braucht doch kein scheuen so
setzt dann brauch ich ausschließlich vor
allem ich nicht strings knochen dudu
kohle braucht vielleicht so der rest
kommt daran jetzt einfach mal hier komm'
essen hier alles rein da alles rein sagt
so der rucksack ist dann auch leer und
dieser hier ist glaube ich er ja der ist
ja ok in rucksack habe ich aber immer
dabei essen auch so bleibe ich
eigentlich alles
so freunde ich habe gerade ein flugzeug
stadt gehört ich glaube das war gomez
aber ich muss eben meine folge jetzt
beenden weil ich schon bei 20 eineinhalb
minuten
wenn es euch gefallen hat dass ich mal
so ein bisschen einfach gequatscht dann
lasst eine bewertung da egal ob positiv
oder negativ schreibt mir die kommentare
wie das jetzt so läuft mit der stimme ob
ich das gut gefällt oder nicht so gut
gefällt das war nix mit der facetime zu
tun die festgeld ist einfach nur zweite
ein bisschen zu hell
ich habe übrigens neuen studie von die
kirche ist mega bequem
der heißt markus und der ist mega
bequemen und ja das hier ist einfach nur
politisch stuhls eigentlich in ganz
anders sieht so aus na gut egal am
schreibt mit dem für die nächste folge
bricht aber den ganzen kisten sortiert
werden nämlich sagen sie was bei mir ist
mal wieder was vielleicht noch ein
wunderschöner tag und